[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the Word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 885 6 7 4 7
once again that's 800 eight three five
six seven four seven now here's your
host from amazing facts international
pastor Doug Batchelor hello friends
would you like to hear an amazing fact
virtually every major pandemic in
history can be traced back to humans
eating or living in close proximity with
unclean animals the bubonic plague is
connected with rats infested with
infected fleas AIDS has been traced to
people eating chimpanzees or African
green monkeys mears is connected with
camels and bats swine flu you've guessed
it connected with pigs West Nile virus
is carried by birds and it's believed
Ebola can be traced to African fruit
bats presently the scientific community
believes that the current corona virus
can be traced to pangolins
sold in a Chinese market along with
other exotic animals perhaps this is one
reason God told Noah to only bring two
of the unclean animals on the ark
otherwise we might not be here today
you know the Bible contains a number of
secrets to avoiding disease and living a
long abundant life stay with his friends
were going to learn more on this edition
of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
Bible questions
hello listening friends welcome to Bible
answers live and in some ways this is a
special program this is a National Day
of Prayer
in addition as people know there is
something of a national crisis while
it's not something of it's been declared
a national crisis the World Health
Organization it says there's a a
pandemic around the world right now but
friends we are still going to be
broadcasting the truth and doing our
best to answer Bible related questions
that maybe even connected with you know
does this appear anywhere in prophecy or
does the Bible shed any light on what is
happening in the world today and so
we're just so glad that you could join
us if you have Bible questions give us a
call the number is 800 four six three
seven two nine seven we are streaming
live if you want to watch on the amazing
facts Facebook page it'll also be in the
Doug Batchelor Facebook page and again
you can call in we still have lines open
800 four six three seven two nine seven
that's 800 God says 800 four six three
seven two nine seven for your Bible
questions and I am Doug Batchelor my
name is John Ross good evening frames
pastor Doug you mentioned at the
beginning of the program I spoke a
little bit about how scientists think
that maybe the coronavirus kind of got a
jump start was through unclean animals
mm-hmm and of course it's never been
part of God's plan for people to eat
unclean animals and we do have a free
offer that goes along with the biblical
principles for good health and we'll be
happy to send that to anyone who calls
and asks but probably be good before we
even get into the program here and take
the calls is to start our program with
prayer mmm you also mention that today
is being a set-aside by the government
to be a special day of prayer I know
even in the Adventist world there are
many who are praying in other churches
so maybe you want to mention that in our
prayer as we open this this evening man
your father in having me thank you that
we have this opportunity to open up your
word and study together and Lord also we
are grateful that you promised
with us in every situation every trial
and difficulty and in particular along
with many other Christians throughout
this country we wish to ask for your
special blessing or we know there's a
lot happening in society and a lot of
decisions being made and we just pray
for your guidance and the Lord we look
to you as the great healer and the one
who can provide and sustain and thank
you Lord that we need not fear for you
have told us never to be anxious for
anything but to bring it all and place
it in your hands and allow you to work
things out according to your will so
pray blessing on the program be with
those who are listening be with us here
in the studio in Jesus name Amen amen
and again pastor Doug that free offer
for tonight we're gonna let people know
about that it's called God's free health
plan and it talks about biblical
principles that you can implement in
your life that all the help help you be
healthy and the number to call for that
is eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven and we'll be happy to
send that to anyone who calls and asks
that's 800 eight three five six seven
four seven absolutely and we know we're
gonna have a lot of calls tonight we
want to try and save as much time as we
can we do still have some lines open so
if you want to get your Bible question
on the program tonight and some might
even have questions is there anything in
the Bible that talks about you know
pestilence and some of these issues our
first caller this evening is Elizabeth
listening right here in Sacramento
Elizabeth welcome to the program thank
you Pastor oz her pastor Doug hope you
doing well my my question is did Jesus
lose his ability to be omnipresent suits
for becoming a human being
dying for us and then even where he is
in heaven and the reason I ask is that
John 16 verse seventh of Jesus says that
is expedient for you that I go away for
if I go not away the comforter will not
come unto you but if I depart I will
send them unto you so it seems like the
Holy Spirit moves through the work of
being present with all rather than Jesus
you know that is a great question and
it's a very deep question and even
before I attempt to answer it I need to
make it clear that there's some mystery
to it I don't want to pretend that I can
explain everything about God because his
ways are as high
of our ways as the heavens are above the
earth and Jobe says he is past finding
out but it appears that Jesus in coming
to earth and taking on the form of man
yet we call this the Incarnation that he
may have at least in part sacrificed
some dimension of his omnipresence now
of course Christ being God he's
omniscient meaning that he knows
everything all the time everywhere and
through God the spirit you know he's
everywhere he said I will be with you to
the end of the world some of his parting
words when he ascended to heaven but
when he rose from the dead he had a body
and there's no record in the Bible of
his appearing in more than one place at
a time you know what I'm saying so it
seems like physically he is not
everywhere at one time now that he's you
know shared humanity with us so I don't
pastor also if you something to add to
that but you know it seems it seems as
though the Holy Spirit comes and he's
the representative of Christ on earth
Jesus is in heaven for us ministering as
a high priest the Holy Spirit is in the
hearts and lives of all believers and
that could be anywhere in every around
the world so it does seem that
throughout all eternity Jesus has in
especially connecting himself with
humanity yeah and that's that's very
unique very special well thank you
Elizabeth you know I'm trying to think
we don't really have a letter we have a
lesson on the Trinity that talks a
little bit about that there would be a
good of death study if you'd like to
receive it it's called the Trinity is a
biblical and we'll be happy to send this
anyone who calls and asks and the number
again is 883 five six seven four seven
that is the resource phone line and as
for the book on the Trinity and we'll be
happy to send it out to anyone who calls
and asks we've got Anthony listening in
New York and throw off into the program
Anthony you there yes hello good evening
pastors how are you good thank you for
calling so I know in Genesis chapter 19
verse 4 I talks about Sodom and Gomorrah
and how they're the men says the men
both
young old came and when the wickedness
trying to get to the angels in locked
house and then the Bible also says in I
think Luke chapter 17 that as it was in
the days of lot so shall it be in the
coming of the Son of Man and so my
question is first were there children
involved with what was going on I know
it says he's gonna know but somebody
said no that mean that there were
children this means young men and old
men but I supposed to know first whether
children involved what was going on
there and then secondly what does that
mean for us today knowing that as it was
then so it will be today in the last
days yeah yeah it's a good question I
think they're I would agree with whoever
said that when it says young and old
it's talking about
young men and old men young men being
you know they could have been anywhere
from 1825 or something and that was
considered a young man back in those
days because people lived in the days a
lot you know Abraham lived to 175 so
there was a large spectrum I guess it's
saying people that had given themselves
over to the New Testament calls it going
after strange flesh and sexual
immorality so yeah I think they were
they weren't children necessarily in
this story yeah all the reason why I ask
is because I see all that's going on
with the young people today and how you
know they're allowing them to have I
guess gender changing their gender found
them to change their gender when they're
still you know before the age of 10
sometimes so I just didn't know if that
was connected or you know it is true
that just before Jesus comes virtually
all of the foundational truths of the
Bible will be under attack
things like creation and marriage and
the distinction between men and women
the Bible says God made them male and
female
there's no you know three or four other
options between those two so we're
living in a very confused society in
that department and and I think it's
unfortunate that the the adults are not
trying to
lead the children in affirming what
their natural gender is and making them
comfortable with that instead we're
creating chaos in their thinking and
saying well you can't really know what
you are or how do you feel today and you
know kids are going through very painful
surgeries that are just really causing
problems later in life yeah anyway yeah
it could be one of the signs of the
times Thank You Anthony appreciate that
good question
they've got e Frank listening from New
York he Frank welcome to Bible answers
live faster Ross my question tonight is
in regards to Jesus as being the
mediator of the Father in heaven I I was
looking at John 3:15 and I've always
read this first on a constant basis and
you know I've never understood the the
relationship that the father and the son
have in administrating certain affairs
on earth for men I would just would like
to also state this we have a serious
problem here
now with this virus and I also look at
the book of Revelation the seven plagues
and they make a comparison and I know
prophecy is something that is undefined
to a certain degree because we don't
know exactly a specific factual basis
what the times in place will be when all
this will happen but I'm just wondering
that if Jesus is the mediator for man on
earth through the father does it mean
that Jesus Christ can make decisions for
the father
apart from kin apart from him because
I'll give you an example years ago I
don't want to sound a little bit
convoluted I have a god-fearing
Christian a woman who was a friend of
mine who's one year older than me and
she constantly heckles me saying that I
because I lived a life of the immorality
that I you know stole things from her
like insects from her backyard that that
God is punishing me and that God can
never
or support me so when I hear things from
people I know saying that I don't
believe in God the Jesus is not part of
the plan with the Father in heaven
I I get confused when I read scripture
and I and in other individuals telling
me that the Bible the God of the Bible
is different from what they believe all
right so that and if I understand right
if Frank some people think that Jesus is
separate from the God of the Old
Testament and that Jesus might make
unilateral decisions separate from God
the Father the Bible teaches that Jesus
and the father are perfectly one because
they're both all-knowing their minds you
might say are perfectly United and
you'll never see an example in the Bible
where Jesus and/or the father are
thinking opposite thoughts on any given
thing because God is perfectly why it's
perfectly good perfectly just both the
father in the Sun and they don't argue
about you know I think we should do it
this way no I think you should do it
this way you know he says even as the
father and I are one and the word one
their means they're united perfectly in
love in their thinking and in wisdom so
for one of them to disagree with the
other would mean one of them knew
something more true or right than the
other which is it in a subs being
all-knowing
so yeah Jesus and the father perfectly
United I believe that makes sense pastor
author am i right no absolutely you know
we do have a full readout to this a
little bit we have a study called saved
from certain death and maybe ties in a
little with what you're saying you Frank
about how can we be sure that God
forgives us and how does Jesus as our
mediator
what role does he play well we'll
explain all of that in the study guide
and we'll be happy to send it to you for
free just call and ask for it it's
called saved from certain death and the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
and again asked for that study guide
called save from certain death mm-hmm
all right thank you so much Frank
next caller that we have is mall and
listening from Tennessee mall and
welcome to the program
hi pastor uh thanks for welcoming me and
bachelor yeah and your question tonight
like my question is the Casso of being a
disciple Luke 14 25 to 35 and I'm trying
to understand that word hating your
loved one all right let me read it for
our friends that are listening and the
way it's worded here could sound
disturbing Jesus sells a multitude in
verse 26 if anyone comes to me and does
not hate his father and mother wife and
children brothers and sisters yes his
own life he cannot be my disciple
now when Jesus says that he's using
something that we would call hyperbole
hyperbole is when you make a statement
and you kind of overstate something
drastically like if you say I'm starving
to death because lunch is ten minutes
late that's hyperbole you're not really
starving to death you're just trying to
emphasize something you're emphasizing
I'm really hungry Paul says the gospel
has gone into all the world well I don't
think that the gospel had gone to
Australia and South American Paul made
that statement he's just saying it had
gone very far so when Christ says if
anyone comes to me and he doesn't hate
his father and mother what he means is
you can't love anyone more than God and
God must be supreme and he says even
your own life you cannot love it of
course I love my life I love my wife I
love my kids but jesus said you don't
love the gift more than the giver and
since God gives us everything he should
really have the supreme love since he's
a creator of everything you know we have
another verse that sort of helps us
understand this little but if you look
in Matthew your question was in Luke
14:26 but if you look in Matthew 10
verse 27 this is the way Jesus puts it
he says he who loves his father his
mother more than me
you mean 3737 Matthew 10:37 he loves his
father his mother more than me is not
worthy of me and he who loves his son or
his daughter more than me is not worthy
of me and that's a good orifice that all
righty well glad we could help I
remember I first read that and I thought
what I thought God said I'm supposed to
love everybody here Jesus is telling me
my wife what does that mean he just
meant that the love for God Great
Commandment as I love the Lord with all
your heart after you love the Lord with
all your heart then you love your
neighbour the horizontal of
relationships as yourself so even in
that verse you've got love for God love
your neighbour that be your family and
yourself
same thing you find in Luke chapter 14
Thank You Marling good question and we
appreciate your tuning in we got Larry
listening in New York Larry welcome to
the program uh hi hide that pastor
Duggan pastor Ross I have a Bible
question for you
yeah you know you know in the Bible how
it says when Jesus comes again
all eyes will see him even those that
pierced him yes well I'm a little
confused by that because when Jesus
comes again the righteous that are going
to be raised first now the ones that
pierced him I don't consider them
righteous the ones that Pearce tomorro
among the wicked so are they saying that
the righteous dead and some of the
wicked I was going to be raised at the
same time so that all all eyes will see
him and if that's the case I'm a little
confused I don't understand it because I
thought the wicked get raised a thousand
years later
all right let's good great question
Larry there will be a small group that
is resurrected when Christ comes again
who participated in his execution and
you can see not only does it say here in
and you were quoting Revelation chapter
1 verse 7 he's coming in the clouds and
every eye will see him including those
who pierced him but then you can look in
Daniel chapter 12 says Michael stands up
there's a great time of trouble there's
a resurrection of life and a
resurrection of condemnation that's
going to happen and then when Jesus is
being tried he tells the high priests
and what verses that Matthew yeah this
Matthew 26 verse 40 64 and let me just
read a pastor day we got right here it
says but the high priest answered it
said to Jesus I put you under an oath by
the Living God tell us if you are the
Christ the
son of God and then Jesus said he
couldn't remain silent any longer said
it is as you have said nevertheless I
say to you hereafter you shall see the
Son of man sitting at the right hand of
power and coming in the clouds of heaven
so it appears as though at least the
high priest Caiaphas and those who play
the leading role in crucifying Jesus
will be resurrected to see in coming
again they specifically ask for proof
they said tell us prove to us that you
are the Christ and Jesus says ok you
will see me you want Laurie it'll be a
review proof it'll be a day of anguish
for them but they will they will be
resurrected to see Christ coming and
then yes you're right there are
destroyed and they are not resurrected
again until the end of the thousand
years now that's not all the way it's
just a small group right we're gonna get
a front-row seat the one time then they
don't want a front-row seat yeah and by
the way that frees up another phone line
friends we do have lines open if you've
got Bible questions tonight one more
time the number is 800 four six three
seven two nine seven you can join us
watch what's happening in the studio now
by going to the amazing facts Facebook
page or the Doug Batchelor Facebook page
and just give us a call lines open who's
next pastor Ross next we got Amy
listening and she is calling from looks
like from Connecticut so Amy welcome to
the program you're on the air with Bible
answers life thank you for having me my
question is about Elijah I know he that
he called fire from the heaven two times
and destroyed two super soldiers so he
did not run away from them but why do
you run away from a woman from Jezebel
you know that is a good question and you
not only have that I mean Peter when
they came to arrest Peter he says Lord
I'm ready to die for you and he pulled
out a sword when the mob came to arrest
Peter but a little while later a girl
says to Peter oh you're one of his
followers and he caves you know I think
part of the reason the lines you got
discouraged was he had gone all day long
on Mount Carmel watching the prophets of
bale carry-on finally this you know
magnificent experience where the fire of
God comes down the profits of Baelor
slain he runs ahead of the chariot of
Ahab he gets rained on in the process
he's sleeping at the gate you know
probably on the ground or stone bench
nobody's treating him very nicely and he
gets this message that after all he was
hoping for a revival after all he had
done Jezebel is still in power and he
thought oh man she's just gonna start
this all over again and he was
overwhelmed with discouragement probably
tired hungry that's why an angel appears
to feed him later he's he's hungry so he
was exhausted a low blood sugar and the
devil got him while he was down so I
don't know that it was just because it
was Jezebel but she was a pretty
conniving woman and he thought you know
I should have killed her when I killed
the prophets of bale but she somehow
we're still in the palace are you there
yeah yeah thank you thank you yeah okay
that makes sense yeah my sense oh oh
maybe she maybe she was influenced by a
stronger power I think she was I think
you're right I think that Jezebel no
doubt it was being influenced by evil
spirits she's the one who's killing the
prophets of God and she was manipulating
they have to kill innocent people for
their property the Bible says that there
was no king that sold himself to do
wickedness like Ahab who Jezebel stirred
up and so yeah she was she's kind of
like Exhibit A in the Bible of a wicked
wicked queen well thank you so much Andy
appreciate your question tonight and got
another line free friends and give us a
call who's next pastor Ross we've got
Lee listening from Arizona Lee welcome
to the program hello pastor Derek hi
thanks for calling hello this question
not
it has to deal with the fact that you
know the the flesh and blood family of
Jesus when he was going you know I've
had some friends me that it was possibly
you know Jewish kids by a previous
marriage or his cousins
but I had been but I've been like
looking in the scriptures and it said
that Joseph did not know his wife and
until after she gave birth to her
firstborn son and it also had me
thinking about messianic prophecy in
Psalm 69 8 where it says I have become a
stranger to my brothers and an alien and
my mother's children
ya know was wondering is it possible
even possible that Jesus could have been
the older brother that he could that
Mary and Joseph could just had a normal
family after you know after Jesus had
gotten well is it possible that you know
she I'm sure was able to do it what you
see in the Bible though is I think
there's really three reasons that most
scholars believe that Jesus was the
first and only of Mary that Joseph Jesus
brothers and sisters that you hear about
actually came from a prior wife that
evidently had passed away and Joseph
when he married Mary for one thing
Joseph is already he's died by the time
Jesus begins his ministry he's never
mentioned again it frequently mentions
Jesus mother and his brothers never
mentions Joseph he's kind of mentioned
in the past tense when it says was not
this a carpenter's son the other reason
is if Jesus was the oldest in Jewish
society it would have been very unusual
for the older brother who kind of took
over for the family to leave home and
become an a tenor at preacher he usually
was the one who would assume the you
know double portion of the inheritance
and take care of the rest of the family
the third reason is when Jesus is on the
cross he commends his mother not to his
brothers which would have been the
normal thing that his own her natural
children would take her into the family
but he can't commence a care of his
mother to his Apostle John so you know
for those reasons and there may be some
others I'm leaving now now the prophecy
that you gave here in Psalm 69 it is a
messianic prophecy but the Messianic
prophecies are often a mixture of
David's own experience and then you see
the shadows of the Messiah in there it's
not all literally always about the
Messiah when he says I've become a
stranger to my brother's an alien to my
mother's children you know David was the
youngest that's not like Jesus David had
brothers that at first did not accept
him that you know even his own brother
when he came to kill Goliath he said
what are you doing here you're supposed
to be home with his sheep when he first
began to run from Saul it tells us he
was by himself a lot later his brothers
joined him just like Jesus so I I'm
still inclined to think that Jesus was
the only son of Mary that the other
brothers were stepbrothers and you know
fortunately our salvation will not hinge
on that that point hey thank you very
much appreciate your question Lea
friends we do have lines open give us a
call with your Bible questions gonna
take a brief break we've got some
important announcements for you and tell
your friends to be tuning in we'll be
back in a few moments
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
charts and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dick index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy to seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
what if you could know the future what
would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named Rahm was violent they were
ruthless
they were determined the Gospel writers
seek his death as a fulfillment of
salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian life call us now
at 800-831-6273 72 97 and pastor Ross
just before we go back to the phones I
want to remind people in our opening
amazing fact not only is this a National
Day of Prayer where we need to be
praying you know the Bible tells us
there in the Book of Chronicles that if
my people called by my name will humble
themselves and pray and seek my face and
turn from their wicked ways then I will
hear from heaven forgive their sin and
heal their land and Solomon says it or I
should say God says that to Solomon
right after he says if I send pestilence
in the land and so we should be praying
along with our spiritual leaders a lot
of churches were not meeting today
they're meeting online as well as the
government leaders we should be praying
God gives them wisdom and humbling
ourselves confessing our sins to the
Lord and and asking him to spare people
from you know some of the fallout in
misfortune that's going to come
connected with this pandemic it appears
at least there's going to be economic
fallout and yet it remains to be seen
what's gonna happen on the medical front
but we do have a free lesson we talked
tonight about all the pandemics that are
connected with unclean animals in our
amazing fact and we have a free study
guide that talks about that that we're
offering anybody
pastor Ross that study guide
it's called God's free health plan and
again we'll send this anyone who calls
and asks the number is 883 five six
seven four seven that is our resource
phone line if you call that phone line
just ask for the study guide called
God's free health plan and if you have a
Bible question our phone line here to
the studio is 800 four six three seven
two nine seven now pastor Doug I I know
it's a lot of folks talking about the
coronavirus and what can we do to boost
our immune system just last week you and
dr. Nedley spent some time talking about
some practical even biblical principles
that help strengthen our immune system
yeah absolutely and we we did a about a
fifteen minute discussion together on
practical things you find in the Bible
and they're connected with what you
would call the New START principles a
new start is dealing with the the
secrets but they're all found in the
Bible to boosting your immune system
we're not selling you any products
friends this is just common sense stuff
that people often neglect that will
strengthen you if if any the common flu
anything comes through it always gives
you more resilience and the New START
stands for NE WS t AR T New START
nutrition exercise any W water s
sunshine T temperance a air our rest and
the last T is trust in divine power and
if people do those things if they get
good nutrition avoiding you the best
thing you can do is eat a healthy diet
and you know certainly don't be eating
the things the Bible calls unclean it's
through eating in proximity with these
unclean animals that all these viruses
have been they've jumped the the barrier
from animal to human if you'd like to
see this video you can actually see it
at the amazing facts website just
amazing facts dollar G you can also see
it on YouTube if you type in the best
Korona prevention I believe is what its
title and you'll be able to see that and
get some good helpful information I
think practical stuff that are
personally yeah ten minutes and you'll
learn a lot all right we're gonna go to
the phone lines on next caller that we
have is let's see we got Niles
from Georgetown Guyana all right miles
welcome to the program oh yeah thank you
thank you for your call for me mark
chapter three in the fourth twenty seven
would you like us to read it yeah yeah
let me read it for your voice is a
little faint because of the Overseas
called so let me read this for our
friends verse 27 of Mark chapter three
no one can enter a strong Mans house and
plunder his Goods unless he first binds
the strong man and then he will be able
to plunder his house and so you're
connect your question about that verse
to defend their property Oh big question
you know first thing is Jesus did not
make this statement really as a
statement for how heavily armed you
should be to protect your home it was
understood in Bible times that a man was
to do all he could to protect his family
in his home and especially if you had a
strong man you are not gonna get at his
family unless you bound him first so
there's a principle there that is sort
of a very basic primal truth that a man
is going to do all he can to protect his
family the main reason Jesus is sharing
this is talking about that you've got to
bind the devil if you want to free
people from his house and in the same
way you know Jesus through his his power
he he gives us the ability to bind the
Satan that people might be set free his
captives might be set free and he goes
on to say if Satan is fighting against
himself he cannot stand but he has an
end so this is this is the context of
what he's talking about but back to your
initial question how far should a person
go in protecting themselves I think that
that's a questionnaire
individual really needs the answer using
common sense you know some people live
in very safe communities where they
don't have to do very much and you know
very low crime rate and pretty good
neighbors and and you know you can
probably lock your door and your you'll
be pretty good there's some people that
may be in homes you know pastor Ross is
from South Africa I remember my first
time to Joburg I was just shocked
everybody had alarms and wire around
their house and glass on their walls and
and these because they had a lot of
crime and people were doing
extraordinary things to protect
themselves and so I guess it would I
would say Niles it depends on where
you're at if someone invaded my home I
would do all I could whether it was a
baseball bat or a weapon to protect my
family if I had a gun or something I'd
probably shoot in the air first try and
scare people off because you don't want
to hurt anybody as a Christian if you
can avoid it so anyway hope that helps a
little bit and a good question thank you
for calling all the way from Guyana next
color that we have is Mindy listening
from looks like Georgia Mindy welcome to
the program my question hi and I'm Marie
born Christian again and I got all the
church for a while and while I was out I
had eight one so my question is will God
forgive me for eating flan while I was
out of the church well whenever your it
pardon me for jumping in I'm sorry the
when you're asking will God forgive you
you're really asking if you know if
eating unclean food is that the
unpardonable sin I'd say of course not
you know when Jesus said that there was
a sin that was unforgivable I don't
think this is what he had in mind we
actually you know so for any sin and
there's people who have left the church
and and you know they've done they've
gone on drunken binges and lived
completely irresponsible
lives and immoral lives and all kinds of
problems and they go through a dramatic
conversion they come back to the Lord
Jesus said whoever comes to me I will in
no wise cast out so whenever we come to
him and we repent of our sins he
forgives us you know we whenever we sin
we get you know a certain amount of
scarring that comes from it and that may
not go away but God does forgive and he
does restore we do have a free book that
we'd be happy to send you a copy of
about what is the unpardonable sin
absolutely the number to call and we'll
send this to you Mindy or anyone wanting
to learn more the number is 883 five six
seven four seven and you can ask for the
book called what is the unpardonable sin
and again we'll send that out to you
anywhere in North America if you're
outside of North America we would
encourage you to take a look at our
website amazing fact so our G and I
think it's under our library section you
can read the book but it's got a lot of
good information there and just one
verse Mindy just to kind of help you
encourage you a mark chapter three verse
31 jesus speaking this is his words he
says therefore our society every sin and
blasphemy will be forgiven him that is
if they repent but the blasphemy against
the Holy Spirit will not be forgiven
them so you know we're talking about the
unpardonable sin there but jesus said
every son other than the unpardonable
sin can be forgiven if we repent now
again the unpardonable isn't just one
really bad sin that a person commits and
God says ah now I'm sorry I can't
forgive you that was too bad because in
the Bible we have examples of God
forgiving people who actually committed
murder and I don't think you can get
anything worse than that
but the unpardonable sudden is one
hardening their heart turning away from
God and that of course will be explained
in that book so I hope you call and
we'll send that right out to you next
caller the behaved looks like we got if
if I Keough if I'm pronouncing that
correctly if I Oh calling from Florida
oh yeah okay welcome and your question
the question that I want to know if any
answer on the Bible in any part of the
books of the Bible about the how the
kids are gonna survive through this
pandemic all around the world is any
salvation for them how people will
survive our kids you said
especially yeah well fortunately the
coronavirus is not having a tremendous
impact on children now as some of the
viruses were very hard on children in
the past other flu viruses but this one
seems to be more affecting people that
are aged there are prophecies where
Jesus said that it is going to be
expected before his second coming he
said there will be wars famines
pestilence earthquakes all these things
are the beginning of Sorrows so you know
we've just seen
there's Wars and famines and earthquakes
and and now we've got a pestilence I
think it's just telling us that we're on
the threshold of the final events but
it's not over he said they'll deliver
you up to tribulation and kill you
you'll be hated of all nations for my
name's sake so there's gonna be time of
persecution God's gonna pour out his
spirit on his church there'll be a time
of great proclamation and yeah they'll
be you know some people are gonna suffer
but I don't think for this particular
pandemic children are gonna suffer
disproportionately compared to grandmas
and grandpas now we understand from the
Bible that yes disease is one of the
signs of the earth getting old of course
there's always mean pestilences in the
past but there is an increase of
pestilence or diseases an increase of
earthquakes and increase of great
famines and fires and these are some of
the things that we are seeing taking
place around us in the world I mean this
is pastor Doug somewhat unprecedented to
have a virus that is so global and
impacting so many people it's we've had
outbreaks in isolated areas in Africa or
in Asia or somewhere but to have
something that's impacting the whole
world this way it's it's truly you know
even after 9/11 9/11 affected
international travel at least in North
America and but now international travel
is being impacted and kids all over the
country in different parts in the
northern hemisphere are being told don't
go to school and you know our boys are
coming home from university right now
and it's like they've cancelled it yeah
for you know next semester and so this
is gonna have a tremendous economic
impact
and the leaders know that so I would say
friends this is a good time to be
sharing your faith make sure your faith
your relationship is right with the Lord
because you know one of the things that
you see in prophecy is that out of fear
people are willing to sacrifice freedoms
and they look for a charismatic leader
to lead the world and Satan seems to say
that he's going to impersonate Christ
before the second coming well this would
be a good time for you know people get
scared and some Savior suddenly appears
mm-hm and folks are ready to follow
anyone during a crisis hey thank you
appreciate your question next caller
that we have jamia listening from Canada
if we pronounce your name correctly
Janna welcome to the program hi hi this
is Juanita
Juanita okay thank you and my question
is how can I become baptized without
joining a church do you mind my asking
why would you want to be baptized
without joining a church I guess I don't
believe fully in the doctrines that most
churches prescribed to alright well
let's talk about this for just a minute
in the Bible
Juanita yes I got my pen and paper ready
okay in the Bible baptism is compared to
marriage in the Bible says husband's
love your wives even as Christ loves the
church I think that's in Ephesians and
if a man said to you you know I love you
on I want to get married but I don't
want to be in the same house with you
would you go for that well I don't right
I guess it would depend on the situation
being single I guess I'm not in a
position I'm not in a position to make
that call or well in the Bible baptism
is called being part it's where you
become part of the body of Christ and
then you and I understand that in is it
first Corinthians 12 pastor ASSA talks
about the different parts of the body
that we have different functions and so
you become part of a family and so it's
so important that when you are baptized
that you are part of
family because it gives you for one
thing accountability that helps you grow
and you may not agree with all the
doctrines I would continue to look for a
church that you felt fit the doctrines
of the Bible there's you know seems like
there's a lot of churches out there
right you know we've got a book we can
send you that talks about baptism isn't
necessary and the other book is dealing
with a search for the true church you
need to find a church family where you
say I want to be committed to be part of
this family part of this body because it
is really no example in the Bible of
people that are kind of Maverick Rambo
Christians that are by themselves
speaking because you know part of a body
if my finger gets cut off and it's on
the ground it doesn't last very long it
has to be attached and you just don't
flourish unless you're interconnected in
the body of Christ I think your point
though wanita is important if we are
gonna join a church we want to make sure
that what the church teaches is in
harmony with the Bible why would you
want to join a church where you have
serious questions about the doctrine or
the teaching so does God have a people
out there who are holding to the truth
of his word and I think that's very
important we find those who are faithful
to his word and then yes baptism is a
beautiful ceremony it's that outward
profession that you're in uniting with
Christ but you want to become part of a
fellowship of believers who are
following the word so you know we'd be
happy to sing you this study it's
actually a book that we can sing you
it's it's not a real a long book but
it's definitely worth reading it's
called the search for the true church
and there are biblical principles that
one needs to apply when looking for a
church you know pastor that we did a
presentation one time where we looked at
some of the reasons for why people
choose the church they choose and it's
kind of interesting some of them are a
little comical well you know it's close
to my house or the preacher is a good
looking or charismatic or I like the
music or the kids program and these are
important things but really the question
needs to be what is the church believe
what do they preach mm-hmm yeah the
foundational teachings the Constitution
and if you wait when he did until you
find a church where you think
everybody's perfect you'll never find
one the part of the reason we go to
church is we need to learn to love God
in our
neighbor and that means yes even in the
church even the disciples of Jesus
sometimes argued among themselves and
but they learned to love each other and
work together and that's what made them
so powerful the number to call is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven that is the resource phone line
and again just as for the book when
either this search for the true church
and anyone wanting to learn what are the
Bible principles that we want to look
for in a church again the number is 883
five six seven four seven asked for the
book called to search for the true
church
I think scholar that we have is Dennis
listening in Sacramento Dennis welcome
to the program hi thank you hey thanks
for calling yes I'm 71 my brother's 63 I
have a fellowship and my my brother kind
of never has he when he was young kind
of fell away from church ease things and
at any rate I'm concerned for his
salvation and I appreciated 1st
Corinthians 7:14 maybe let you read it
ok people yeah it says here for the
unbelieving husband is sanctified by the
wife and the unbelieving wife is
sanctified by the husband otherwise your
children would be unclean but now their
holy so are you wondering if because of
your faith and your family that it can
have a sanctifying influence on your
brother well I'm wondering if my parents
faith has a salvation alene but does it
have an effective influence in spite of
his disinterest sort of for the two
brothers and my sister my main focus
right I think I just worry I studied for
that tried to find something on that in
the Bible I didn't really find anything
yeah that is a great question you know I
think the principle in 1st Corinthians 7
he's talking about a husband or wife
you've got children at home
children are you want to have the
believing sanctifying influence of the
believer in the family when someone does
get older and they reach the age of
accountability and especially if they're
not within their parents home so to
speak
where's that verse in Ezekiel where it
says the son shall not bear the sin for
the father nor shall the father bear the
sin for the son but the righteousness of
the righteous will be upon them every
man will be judged as an individual now
the prayer is I take it your parents are
not alive anymore no longer yeah yeah so
I the prayer is that your parents have
stored in heaven in behalf of your
brother can still have a sanctifying
influence in reaching him but and you
renew your faith yeah I reminded God of
that and my grandparents well you know
what don't give up sometimes God waits
until the very end my I prayed with my
brother the day he died and he asked me
to pray with him then where he used to
make fun of my religion so don't get
discouraged just sometimes God answers
those prayers at the eleventh hour and
they just you continue to pray for your
brother and but he is at the age of
accountability now so he needs to come
to the Lord
yeah kids of age well I don't know where
you found that but you know the closest
thing I can think of is when Jesus was
12 it says something bout when kids are
seven I think it does I I know that in
the biblical way of doing things when a
child a boy reached the age of 12 he
would often accompanies father for
sacrifices and in the case of Jesus he
went to the temple when he was 12 and I
think in the Jewish mind and again it's
not a hard age because every child is a
little different but when we working
with children preparing them for baptism
we want them to be able to make the
decision for themself understand the
importance of their decision and
probably somewhere around 10 12
depending upon the
enough to understand sin and repent of
this rights and ask for forgiveness when
they know the difference between right
and wrong and what the what the stakes
are you know God is good he judges us by
those things hey thank you so much
Dennis hope that helps a little bit and
we'll pray for your brother too
we've got Robert listening in Washington
Robert welcome to the program hey Robert
bastard I think we got time for a short
question before we sign off so we better
get to it okay I just want you to
explain to me John 16:33 why should we
be a good tear because Christ has
overcome in the world what does it mean
that crisis overcoming the world well I
think is he of course was victorious in
living in this world you know the
world's always trying to bring people
down and turn them to sin and make us
give up our convictions and and
worldliness you know the Bible says love
not the world or worldliness Jesus was
not impacted by it he lived a sinless
life he overcame the world and he said
because I've overcome the world
I can now die as your sacrifice and
provide forgiveness for your sins so
cheer up we win in the end is what he's
saying now we know how the story ends
you got anything I was just gonna answer
that you know in this life we do a
trials and tribulations we're living in
a simple looted world but because Jesus
has all become the world we have hope of
forgiveness and grace and eternal life
and that is something for us to be or
have good cheer about or be happy about
so you know this this is probably a very
appropriate verse for the things that
our world is going through right now
there's a lot of fear out there and
people are worried about what's gonna
happen tomorrow and what's gonna happen
with my investments and my health but
Jesus says the good news is we know the
way the story ends he has overcome the
world and he promises to give victory
the greatest victory of all is eternal
life to those who trust in him amen and
you know the other thing is people say
oh if I'm a Christian it says I'll have
tribulation I think people forget he
says in the world you'll have
tribulation
everybody's got tribulation everyone has
problems mm-hmm and sometimes I'll see a
personal thing boy that couple they got
everything they want that got it made
there
enlarged there's you know they're rich
and healthy and then you find out why
they got some serious bribes you knew
nothing about it seems like everybody's
got problems and you you know the life
is like going down a river and you're
gonna have Rapids and some calm water
and some more Rapids and you just learn
to enjoy the ride trust the Lord along
the way and just pray that you can be
you know a good witness and do his work
but don't be discouraged when when God
told Joshua I want you to lead the
people into the Promised Land he told
them Joshua chapter 1 think four or five
times he says be courageous be
courageous be very courageous and that's
like saying cheer up
don't be discouraged you're gonna win
they had a lot of battles but they won
and he retired in a a peaceful meadow so
hey you know tear up friends I know that
we're hearing the news and most news is
not good news these days as all kinds of
fear and foreboding when Jesus was in
the boat with the disciples on that
stormy sea they were fearing for their
lives and they woke up the Lord and
asked Lord do you not care that were
perishing and he woke up and calm the
ocean and said where is your faith so
friends Europe all is gonna be well God
is gonna he's on the throne and at the
same time remember we need to keep the
word going out some people get so
frightened during times like this they
forget to support their churches and
Christian ministries where would we be
if programs like this suddenly aren't on
the air because in the panic people
forget and so we do appreciate your
remembering to support ministries like
amazing facts and others that are
bringing spiritual hope to millions you
can go to the website amazing facts at
dot o-r-g and you can tell us you enjoy
the program click donate keep us on the
air God willing we'll talk and study
next
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts International
a faith-based ministry located in
Granite Bay California
[Music]
hello friends pastor Doug Batchelor here
with amazing facts Kareem was divorced
pregnant and very concerned about her
future but God saw her in her desperate
loneliness and confusion and he used a
co-worker to share an amazing fact DVD
that led Kareem to our website here at
the website she studied our life
changing free online Bible studies what
she learned there transformed her heart
and today Kareem has a lasting peace
she's baptized and part of a nurturing
church family now you friend have an
opportunity to help someone today and to
make an eternal difference from where
people like Kareem you're a simple
investment of faith and amazing facts
will keep growing and reaching more
people with God's life-changing word
would you prayerfully consider sending a
gift today to help others know Christ
and the wonderful truth that changes
hearts and it's easy to make a donation
give us a call at 877 five zero six one
seven five one the number again eight
seven seven five zero six one seven five
one or just visit give dot amazing facts
dot o R G or send your gift to peel box
10:58 Roseville California nine five six
seven eight
thank you for studying the Word of God
with me today and I hope that you'll
plan now to join me again next week as
we discover more amazing facts
word of god
[Music]
for life-changing Christian resources
visit AF bookstore calm
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word visit our website at WWF Axio
RG and sign up for our free Bible study
course and make sure to check out our
online bookstore at AF bookstore comm
which offers thousands of inspiring
books DVDs and more to help you get the
most out of God's Word to take advantage
of the offers you've heard on this
broadcast
call us at $887 RG did you enjoy this
program make sure to tell your family
and friends tune in next time for more
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions